Kim jong-un returned to Pyongyang while
differences emerged between US and North
Korean accounts of the summit North
Korean state media calls the summit an
epoch-making meeting and says the
stability of the Korean Peninsula is
thanks to the proactive peace-loving
measures taken by Kim Ben Tracy is
monitoring the North Korean reaction
from Singapore Ben good morning good
morning so that is charitably what you
would call spin from the North Koreans
they are using this summit now to try to
position Kim jong-un as an equal to
president Trump but there are
differences between the North Koreans
and president Trump's version of what
happened at their meeting these pictures
on the front page of the North Korean
newspaper today are exactly what the
regime wanted its people to see Kim
jong-un looks like a respected world
leader not a brutal dictator from a poor
and isolated country in Pyongyang the
summit is being described as historic
and a new era in u.s. North Korean
relations the North Koreans claimed it
was Kim jong-un who demanded that the
u.s. halt with the regime calls
irritating and hostile military
exercises on the Korean Peninsula a
major concession by President Trump we
will be stopping the war games which
will save us a tremendous amount of
money the joint us-south Korean
exercises have taken place for decades
they are designed to keep the more than
28 thousand American troops stationed
there
prepared for combat we were on board the
USS Ronald Reagan last November during a
large naval exercise off the Korean
Peninsula
if the
they can launch a fighter jet off his
carrier once
of course they then have to get molded
fighter jets back onboard this is how
they do
President Trump called these provocative
war games the very same language the
North Koreans use in their anti-us
propaganda it's a very provocative
situation so under the circumstances
that we're negotiating a very
comprehensive complete deal I think it's
inappropriate to be having war games
before the summit president Trump said
he would not give the North Koreans
anything until they completely
denuclearize but the North Koreans are
now saying that they actually agreed to
a step-by-step process and that usually
means North Korea gets incentives along
the way John Ben Tracy Fores in
Singapore thanks Ben those incentives
might be lifting sanctions that's the
big question yeah I'm I was struck this
morning that the u.s. military
spokesperson in South Korea says they
have received no updated guidance on
this and that the military exercises
scheduled for the fall are a go as of
now you know that's maybe that's why I
might Mike Pompeo is headed there too
yes straight to sort it all out to
translate what we just saw yeah and I
talked to somebody the military
yesterday who said they're waiting to
hear details from Pompeo so even within
in the US there's confusion